[Music]
sorry i'm going to turn the game up a
little bit cause it's quite quiet
[Music]
this book belongs to
jasmine oh
yegmanix
hello channel is it okay if i call you
that it's a bit before
i know but we've only just met let me
introduce myself
i'm isabelle barbara cook most people
call me izzy
not dad he calls me titch so what was
this
he had
hey my little brother ben calls me isbo
i call him he who choose curtains
he likes red for breakfast and blue for
dinner
and then there's
shot either what
oh i can move it into place gotcha top
tea drinking buddy
should you be drinking tea at your age
guardian of the biscuit in
ah i can't get my tea and
this is pinkie
i think she's jealous of your journal
it's quite cool today is my unique take
on
um platforming dad made his best journal
mum and gran started the singing ben
gurgled along
i blew out the candles i like that you
can move these as well
where would this go oh cool
that's cool
to be taller than dad i know the
struggles
since i was little i've always dreamed
of
becoming a writer
this is where you come in journal
i used to want to be a writer fun fact i
used to write
short stories all the time
[Music]
oh grand coming out with all the hard
facts
gran always says
writes a writer a writer writes
a writer writes no one
ever got anything just by wanting it
that's true
i'll let this grind
how do i get down there good
help
[Music]
am i being stupid do i go on i guess
that birthday wish was a waste then
brown said writing is about exploring
your thoughts
it helps you unlock your feelings so
true
does do any of you journal this is uh
interesting question
do any of you journal
cute i like this so sweet
[Music]
gangsta granny what what what type of
book is that
i love it i'd like to write something
that will make grand
smile oh you don't have to apologize
about little acorns
growing into big trees is that to make
me feel better about my height
hmm
[Music]
i i journal it really helps like if you
have an anxious mind with a lot going on
it's the best thing just write it down
see it all sometimes i write down things
and then find connections and you can
just draw
like lines how am i gonna ah
cute i love this it's so simple
or about my writing
[Music]
i want to write a story but what kind
a romance
science fiction
i agree a drama
is my humor too weird same comedy
horror where's horror we're getting
somewhere scary
find something scary no she won't a
fantasy story okay that's cool
oops when i was kid in year six
to say goodbye to from like primary
school to secondary school me and my
best friend wrote each other a story
with like us being the main characters
to say goodbye it was super cute
she wrote story about me meeting um
busted that band
so how do i start my fantasy story
once upon a time what did you say
um i'm not good at writing i'm very
visual on expressing thoughts and said
well at least you know you know what
helps you express your thoughts that's
the main thing isn't it
just trying to find what works for you
no one said this would be easy
again from the top
not so far away in the land of
oh astoria that's nice
a place of peace and magic
the lifted girl named
oh sounds noble spiritual
oh what do we want guys you can help me
choose someone who confronts
monsters oh i like that can we choose
that
monsters i want monsters
okay i know i said i like you guys but i
want monsters
how lucky that you have no yeah well
this is like about narrative right so
by the bright color yeah castor is one
of
monsters
[Music]
hey thanksgiving with malakai
making the lights flash
[Music]
oh yeah
so i get like this warning flash
whenever i get donation
whoa
there lids a girl named georgia everyone
knew her by her
the bright color of her
should we say green she's like looks
like a forest
girl all purple's quite cute too
green or purple it's like a club in your
room
yeah who needs clubs
don't think any one of us misses clubs
we're not the club in type i don't think
i don't know i could be wrong
okay jamie wants to scream for a forest
girl i think i'm going for green as well
warning you have money warning you have
money
hell yeah um
r2 garcia wants purple hot damn
i'm gonna go for green sorry maybe next
time
maybe next time to begin her adventure
in fact she'd been preparing for it her
whole life
for she was the only apprentice of the
village guardian
does the exclamation marks not work it
should work
cool let's go and get that little star
there
all characters in the story are
fictitious any relation to persons
living
pure coincidence okay okay
everyone was very fond of georgia her
heart was
full of curiosity and compassion the
visitors agreed
that no one was
oh what do we want okay r2 this is your
chance to shine what do you want
do you want kind she cared for others
and like to make him fruit punch
do you want smart she loved learning and
went
nowhere without her books would you want
playful
she was happily mischievous and always
found something to play with
which one should we go for this game put
me to sleep with this music
it is nice
[Music]
why you guys choose i'm just going to
double check
playful is more fitting for you i agree
aaa
ah
someone set off a party in here
yeah forrest is definitely one weird
okay should we go for playful then
playful nice let's do it
as playful as her
i like this i like that we can kind of
choose where the story goes
in the land of astoria
there lived a young girl named georgia
she was playful and loved using her wit
and imagination
suddenly a faint speck of light floated
down
and began to buzz around georgia
hello little firefly
let's head back to the village the
firefly
shared george's excitement hello
they are all over the place because i
i fought a giant with them right firefly
yeah yeah
[Music]
okay this marble fell
from a passing star
wait is that secrets
wait how do i
is that shift oh okay gotcha
down
this one was the class eye of a sea
sprite
it's super cute oh yeah
this one's almost as pretty as you
firefly
almost
come on firefly the village is just a
bit further down
i love doing that the bridge was an
old creaky affair careful georgia
careful georgia imagines shark fins
circling below phew we made it firefly
georgia knew many secret paths back to
the village
like this one
she loved feeling the roots around her
as if the tree
was giving her a gentle hug
that's one spiky hug better not get any
spinners
oh can we go into here and now again
just one more little slide
thanks for hosting wait i can't see who
did it
thanks for helping uh hoping hosting
john anta jonat john john a tank
jesus why can't i speak
here we go
[Music]
the old cargo barely used
this game will be great for kids to the
village
georgia couldn't wait to show her
firefly the village
maybe run on the rooftops or
prank the village builders look firefly
[Music]
home
the warm lights and enticing smells
elder ava happy birthday georgia
i've made a new friend one of our sacred
fireflies this is a very
special thing indeed does
this mean yes
it is time would you fetch me that box
please
ava was sure that georgia would rise to
the occasion
do i have to what oh
oh cool
[Music]
go ahead open it
this will store all the magic words you
find
some will stay with you others are
fleeting
they will help you overcome any obstacle
now your training is complete
congratulations new guardian of the
fireflies
guardian but that's you
guardian in retirement now
you should head to the shrine tree for
the other fireflies blessing
i'll join you shortly dear
uh how do i get out
oh that way a little something of mine
to mark the occasion
elsa ava reached inside her pocket
and handed georgia a gift
ava's favorite pendant
set with a giant
let's do emerald
someone made my room cute off you go
i'm so proud of you georgia
happy birthday
i can't wait to try out my magic book oh
damn
the police are here
look at this slide and all at once
georgia was surrounded by the hustle and
bustle of village life
kind of would expect more noise here but
okay
uh okay how did you do that
i'm the guardian of the firefly
uh-oh sorry about it
that was amazing the best thing i've
seen
all morning i think they don't care
about their planks
sorry about that why do we have to be on
cargo duty all the time
georgia loves to bring stone over the
rooftops
but not today
uh ah missed
look george
what do you want me to do do you want
any um
stones other
today the firefly shrine was waiting
she looked over her bustling treetop
village
this was all she knew yeah elder basses
gave me a portis
did it work did it right looks better
than ever
smell that that's the center paradise
but inside she was still curious hey
georgia
happy birthday happy birthday
good to see you georgia but georgia has
one but that's different
about the world that lay beyond
quite a collection of accents that's so
true jamie
it's like everyone just comes from a
random different part bridge suede
in the warm breeze it [ __ ] creek
with a gentle familiarity as
georgia crossed it this is so
cute oh my god so cute
what is that something keeps
disconnecting it's annoying
don't know what that is it's pretty fair
i have so many things connected to my
computer it's crazy
haven't seen that book for a while
georgia you have to see the fireflies
let me get repeat
[Music]
blast
[Music]
don't worry about it i'll use my magic
word
georgie couldn't wait to see the
fireflies soon they bless her
as new village guardian
[Music]
this is so feel good
[Music]
magic
i love i love how it's connected
georgia crawled through the dank dark
tunnel
it didn't feel like being hugged at all
no it feels pretty suffocating
[Music]
oh wow
oh no
oh
okay so can i just
the sacred bell to announce her arrival
that paint is just like being engulfed
by the chain
hello at last the
tree was in sight home to the fireflies
whose ancient energy kept the village
safe from harm
[Music]
hey grandma she is strong show them what
you can do
oh okay
[Music]
yes i can finally retire
now she was part of it
forever
and so grandma's using you firefly guard
she just doesn't want to do the hard
work baby was yet to come
hello journal oh wow this time of the
year
it gets dark so early
like the day it's just an accident oh
that's cool i like
the night is how the world really works
stars and fireflies glowing in the dark
i've never actually seen a firefly
do you think that matters journal
glowing things are crayoff especially in
[Music]
nature
[Music]
nature has all cool things oh
cool
[Music]
on holiday in wales grand and i would go
to the beach
and look up at the stars so cool
but one night we looked down instead
the stars were shining in the water it
was like the sky
got flipped upside down
[Music]
we took off our shoes and socks
and waded into the water as we walked
over the pebbles
pebbles so cute glowed beneath our toes
[Music]
gran said it was called bioluminescence
i've seen water being moved
back and forth by the child
[Music]
[Music]
what
how do i get back
i knew it was just little creatures but
it
felt like magic
[Music]
i got up very early the next morning
i sneaked into the kitchen got a janja
and went down to the shore to where i'd
seen the plankton
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that evening i was so excited
i carefully put the jar on my bedside
table
greatest oh that's the greatest idea
ever
but it didn't glow i was
devastated
i showed gran the jar she laughed
gran always says you
nature put a [ __ ] in cork
you can't put a gargantuar
you can't put a cork in nature they need
sunlight and nutrients from the tide
bran
knows about those things she used to be
a marine biologist
[Music]
[Music]
brown bought some special algae that
would grow at home
we spent the whole day planning it
that's pretty cool water obviously
[Music]
i'm cute
we took pictures for gran's photo album
for our future self to remember
oh that's cute how the tank took ages to
fill
how he took turns stirring the algae in
how happy we were when we had it all set
just needs time to develop
science
[Music]
after six days the algae was ready
i put the tank on my desk and ran my
finger through the water
my own bits of magic i love these little
bit interactive bits where you just like
move the word to do the thing
[Music]
until something incredible
izzy
that was mom she just got a call
she has to leave now it sounded
really bad i have
a weird feeling
in my stomach
something i don't know how to deal with
we just heard that gran has had a stroke
i don't want to believe it i can't lose
her
i knew i was gonna do something like
this it was
way too nice and happy
george woke from a hazy distant
dream something unnatural had stirred
her from slumber
[Music]
[Music]
the story is like how she's dealing with
the real world situation i guess
georgia a giant creature is attacking
our village
there must be something wrong get to the
tree at one
okay
[Music]
and suddenly georgia was surrounded
by smoke and cinders
don't worry the firefly is here she
hurried past the crackling
[Music]
she looked at her burning treetop
village
this was all she knew
this was home
attack on titan oh no she needed to get
to the fireflies
oh thanks jamie i'm glad you're enjoying
the lights you're so right about audio
though
i definitely need to get some sort of
audio going on
[Music]
i can rise
[Music]
[Music]
the bridge was beyond repair
it wasn't just learn a new magic word
hell yeah
no not that one wait
oh oopsies
i need to get on there first okay now we
rise
a terrifying noise echoed from beyond
the village gate
don't worry sydney i'll never forget you
guys and i'll never be a big
streamer
soon she would prove herself as the new
village
guardian i can do this
yeah you can right firefly yes
i wonder if it pit purple would be a
purple fire not
deny the creeping
terror the
earth yawned below her
made it that was scary
this tree did not comfort her
it was as scared as she was
with nobody around to extinguish them
fires burned out of control
danny a lot of new magic
a strange blaze crackled ahead
is that fire
i've never seen a flame like that
the sacred bell lays silent
on the ground raparo
[Music]
nearly there
speak the incantation
no no no where are the other fireflies
send me a head to all the colors
please be here please be here soon
the dreadful realization dawned on
georgia
[Music]
fireflies
a new determination rose in her
she would find
what does she want should we give her
knowledge in the fire of life or
revenge should we tell her evil
what should we do should we turn her
evil
should we give her more fireflies should
we give her knowledge
shall we turn our evil should she be the
next darth vader
what do you think
it thinks knowledge
is power very issue
james has knowledge okay so should we go
with knowledge we're not going with
revenge we're not gonna make her evil
okay we'll stay sweet and nice knowledge
elder ava something took the fireflies
i know our people will fall sick without
them there has to be a reason why this
happened
i'll find out
big hugs
i'll be back with answers go and may the
love of this village guide you
always bye granny
georgia took a deep breath she knew
what she had to do she would find
answers
one way or another the earth
and yes it was exhilarating
wondrous and terrifying
fear was at her side
and hope in her heart but
things were about to get me worse
much much worse
oh dragons
but georgia would not slow down
not the crumbling path
lol i died
not for crumbling paths guys
what do i do now all right
sorry what was the story i totally
missed it could i die
no oh well i'm sure we'll start again
not for giant monsters there you go
she would get the fireflies back yeah
no matter what she would catch
the dragon no wait
she raced forward and there's nowhere to
go
hello journal we went to see grand today
in the hospital
it looks like
a big grey fortress
[Music]
i'm sure we can all relate to this in
some way which makes it even more sad
to find the right room
dad let me open the door
gran has a big cozy bed at home
nothing like the hospital one she was in
[Music]
lying in there she looked so
small i don't remember her being that
small
i don't like this story it's too like
relatable
he's sad
john stop
i should have stopped lying
gran's eyes were open but she struggled
too
choose pronounce find
find find the right words
she just couldn't
[Music]
speak properly the doctor said it was
called dysphasia
it was caused by the stroke
she's usually so talkative but
now she kept stopping
mid-sentence as if all the words
she could find were just
and then grant started coughing they put
an oxygen mask on her
i told her she looked like darth graham
i like that
she smiled at that
that reminds me of grande telling me
how she took mum to the cinema
a long long time ago
when mum was my age
a grand story gran
and mum went to my favorite movie mum
fell asleep star wars
but graham fell in love with it when i
was little
gran would show it to me on a battered
video gazette
graham would laugh at the robots and
guess a funny smile
whenever the scruffy looking smuggler
showed up we'd watch it until we could
quote
all the best lines we laughed a lot once
she gets out
we're going to watch them all over again
and when the next movie arrives
gran and i are going to go to the cinema
together
[Music]
and soon grand and i will be playing
games again
coolest round ever
i can't wait
this time i'll be all her high scorers
gave her crown that'll be me when i'm
older for sure
brown's a tough cookie yeah in video
games
and everywhere else
oh sydney yeah i need me
so sweet so relatable the story
i've never seen her cry before
she looked so sad i didn't know what to
do
so i made her a cup of tea oh that's
really cute
uh how do i make tea i'm english
the worst english present it's water
first then milk i know how to make tea
all right
i just don't i don't drink it often
i drink like green tea and stuff
but i make my mama tea
she likes a lot of milk
who puts the milk first that must be a
northern thing
i know no one that does that no judging
just maybe a little bit
just like friends she said
excuse me how do i get up there
mum said gran was getting tired
i said she's getting better
oops mum said she felt helpless
i said she was just sleepy mum said
gran's going to i said she's going to be
fine
everything is going to be fine
all you need is a leap of faith
will graham still be grand
after this
of course she'll be fine oh i can get
the black ones
to like have dark thoughts that is going
to get better
right let's have a look at this
i'm gonna have a look at the darkness so
worried
what if
got to keep positive mum needs me too
i'll show graham my story mum as well
they'll enjoy reading it i hope it helps
what else can i do
i just need to finish my story so
where are we
after the dragon attacks the village
georgia set out
in search of answers leaving elder ava
and her village behind her journey took
her to
a vast desert
with a guardian
who got it because it is
[Music]
he's home he's home
hey photonic boson
yes georgia had pursued the dragon far
far from home
the desert spread out before
[Music]
a glow in the sand i'll get you safely
another firefly escape from the dragon's
grass
this week
there was something very unnatural about
it
a little wind won't stop me
[Music]
please close your mouth i'm gonna get a
mouthful of sand
hold on
oh there's a firefight back here
[Music]
[Music]
that noise
[Music]
go anyways
but george's will would not
break that easily
hell yeah is that a used one time or
forever magic hey
come back here forever magic word
i really need your help i said god
surprise
really who does that big bag of wind
think he is
look whoever you are far
magic too to deal with it okay
see ya
[Laughter]
that sorted mr grumpy pants out the
yawning cave
burrowed deep into the earth
home to wondrous life easily scared
oh did i stare was my was it me
oh yeah the firefly scared it
this
[Music]
uh hey joey foo jorifo
uh i think this game is good it's very
different i mean it's not
like it depends on what you like really
feel like a narrative
it'd be great for kids like a great
little uh game
to play with kids it's extremely unique
in
its narrative storytelling
if that's the kind of stuff that you
like
[Music]
oh i see
oh
uncovering the unknown
far below the rolling dunes
yeah i think it's doing quite a good job
of like um talking about real world
swimming
desert pirates in a way that would
maybe
ah hi sir
of course i can just leave that word
there
take it away
i'm a ufo nice to meet you ufo
hey frank good thanks how are you
interesting
deep under the desert sands
georgia found
one of them will work a long forgotten
chamber
the plants recoiled at the sound of her
footsteps
but there's a firefly up there
i guess i can't
broken remains of greatness
repair and break on the same thing kind
of contradicting itself but
the silence
oh no magic words silence
i think this might be a one-time thing
[Music]
is this no it's not
ah fresh air
[Music]
oh yeah yeah this is working
[Music]
all right nearly halfway there
a familiar foul tempered voice
drifted down
[Music]
wait for an invite rude it's just
[Music]
please oh
word magic
georgia had disarmed the gin his
fury cool cool
fortunately his voice was very
very small
but the desert guardian would not let it
rest
hey stop it
i can just jump over everything
[Music]
i need to find the dragon
i really don't
[Music]
oh his face fell off
that's it for so long
[Music]
she loves sliding wow he got rid of
sunky boots again
now what's all this as she looked around
this lonely desolate place
georgia wondered why would
anyone choose to live here
there had been people here
once upon a time
what happened to them
who were they
good questions
the dome was empty but for a pool of
water
an inviting place to rest
george's thoughts drifted to the people
that once had lived here oh
what do we want guys she was sure they
must have been
mmm merchants why is oh philosophers
oh i mean i don't know
what do you guys want
i look down and all i see is babylonians
it was merchant anyone else wanna
wanna have a a gypsy for what it could
be
all right merchants it is just to
determine the kind of people that you
meet
maybe if so be calling me philosophers
but
oh true maybe i should buy some things
oh it's updated the room a bit
a distant roar
i'll catch you yes
the ancient statues toppled before
georgia
bye mountain statue verbing
industrious merchants
you put a lot of effort in into
that one shop
fall before me a lot of uh advertising
budget i see
but behind georgia a grumpy mumbling
could be heard
him again let's move
the desert guardian was frantically
looking for georgia
stop hiding from me he would surely find
her eventually
wouldn't he
easy
george's hope guided her and the firefly
[Music]
i don't know which way to go so
i don't want to progress
[Music]
uh is she okay
[Music]
i think i broke the game a little bit
that's okay
it's just kind of uh levitated through
the
through the wood there
do
it must leave it must
they mustn't know hmm well
now i'm curious yeah you definitely play
this game
for the narrative because there's like
no way you can
do anything wrong per se but
it's quite nice to just have
have games to play where you don't have
to worry about anything that's not no
wrong or right really you just
enjoy the story just going on with the
right
switch off for a bit
especially because this game would be
really good for kids
what is it with this guy
what's your oh
oh
i must see no no no no
what has you so worked up old windbag
the past the past
it stays hidden it must
so he's trying to hide something from us
the old days so little left
best forgotten look
whatever it is you don't want me to see
i'm sure we can
no no you cannot go further
how can i get him to listen
would she break the gin statue or repair
it
no obviously gonna repair it
i think
[Music]
why because it looked ugly broken you
aren't
listening but you look calmer now
i i do not understand
[Music]
why
[Music]
what's happened here what did you do
i failed
more than ten times
[Music]
let me show you
hold up just go get this firefly
oh wait there's one down there as well i
didn't see that one
oh how do i get up here
can i clean the statue
huh ah good
got two more have i missed any i don't
think so
[Music]
i was once worse it was
[Music]
[Music]
and what did you do
nothing i believed that there was no
danger
i was wrong they paid the price
my being here must have brought back
painful memories
that is as it should be to feel
something
even pain after all this time
for that i thank you
i don't need your thanks but i
do need to know if you've seen a dragon
around here
it has come and gone but
there is something you should know about
that beast
what was that
is he the danger that wrecked his town
my friend knowledge will be yours in
time
use it more wisely than i did
hello journal hello journal
today at school i got my history essay
back
i wrote about vikings i love vikings
mr collins didn't like it
i won't be showing this mum
[Music]
sometimes school can be so
just disheartening i was talking about
it today
how um i did
uh so someone that i work with is like
we're obviously doing artistic jobs and
um
we both basically failed our in school
which is really weird because
we're doing like artistic jobs now but
things like art in school
is subjective um
but when you're a kid to be told by
teaching like you're not very good even
though you think what you've done is
like really cool
it can be enough to stop them
doing things that they love sometimes
which is sad
oh
she has enough to worry about
vikings are the best they're tall
[Music]
they love conquering
and fire fire
like a hair vikings are basically
all kinds of awesome the truth
i could really use them awesome right
now
uh so yeah when i did so i did a levels
and then
i went to college after a levels because
i actually
failed um art um mainly on my
photography module because my
teacher just told me that what i did was
like so bad i had to redo everything
but when i did college i had a
photography module there as well
and i really liked the pictures i took
for my a-level photography so i decided
to like maybe just try and reuse those
photos because i still like them
and i got full marks distinction and
told that i had a really good eye for
photography
it's just so stupid it's so weird
i got her old photo album out
i wanted to see gran like i remember her
when she was awesome
[Music]
but every time i close my eyes
i see her in that horrible bed
we're visiting the hospital later today
when we arrived grand was asleep
her skin looked so thin almost
see-through
like tissue paper she was grand
shaped but empty
i mean that's silly right journal
it's just gran
but somehow it isn't
it's not her
[Music]
she woke up after a few minutes but
it didn't seem like she knew who we were
why why is this happening
why her it isn't fair
why journal
[Music]
still can't speak properly it's so
cruel she can't tell us anything
like what she wants to eat
or how she feels
and what's worse everyone pretends
they're having a real conversation with
her but they're not
you're doing fine barbara the doctor
said to her
you just need some time hospitals should
make you
better
she's so ill now
come on
i want her better now just wait time is
a healer
i thought that was his job i wish we
could help her
it makes me so mad
the nurse said it was dinner mom had
ordered gran
soup and a jacket potato but when gran
tried
to eat by herself
she kept dropping her cutlery
i've seen her inhale a packet of half
miles
yeah this is getting really sad
[Music]
then i noticed mum had ordered her
mushroom
soup mushroom gran calls them nature's
bogeys
i love mushrooms
what do we do with these guys then
[Music]
oh
am i just trying to push them off or am
i trying to give them to the
big mushroom daddy big mushroom daddy
i think i'm just pushing them off
[Music]
i just want to get in between here
i reminded mum about the mushrooms
she got that look and banged the spoon
against the bowl
there was lip passing but
looking at gran i had to help her
[Music]
i still had some loose change so i ran
down to the entrance hall you're a
blesser
or i'd seen a vending machine on the way
[Music]
[Music]
in
egg sandwich hurrying back to 305
i couldn't help but grin they didn't let
me back in
adult talk wait outside
that's what they said
so i waited on a bench until mum came
out the room
she said nothing just
took me to the car we didn't speak a
single word not at the car park
not during our drive home
dad had made pies for tea i just
wasn't hungry dad said i needed to eat
i said if gran wasn't going to eat
oh i slammed the door no that was that i
guess
and flumped onto my bed i still had the
egg sandwich
[Music]
oh that's good
it was all mushed up everything is all
mushed up
that is mean mom doesn't care
and pie is stupid
[Music]
maybe i should just try to write myself
past stupid let's see
last time georgia was plunging down
into the dark below but the gin spell
slowed her fall
down and down she went
tumbling helpless
[Music]
then and there georgia started to
thrash scream or cry
let's have a thresh rash but the
darkness didn't care
as georgia hurtled through the darkness
her helplessness no longer made her feel
scared
it made her feel frustrated
angry she wanted answers
okay
the jinn's magic gently released her
into the unknown
now where am i
firefly can i break it excuse me
can i break with you um
can i raise you okay where's the silent
one
why can't i break it
oh that okay that was weird
oh oh i missed two i actually did miss
the ground was
worn at least
just my luck
and what's that molten stone
she'd seen nothing like this in her
forest home i
really like playing around with the
village kids
a stalactites hung above getting
decidedly
precarious
i wonder if i can die none of this seems
welcoming
i don't at all okay so you can die in
the game
oh really but you can
none of this seems welcoming none at all
careful oh
jeez i think who noticed that
helps you so much it even tells you what
word you should be using
although i still have got that wrong a
few times something was unnerving about
the
i knew pendulum
um can i hold please
this way
this is ridiculous
absolutely i need to find whatever is
causing this and stop it
or i'll be smooshed
um
i'll probably end the stream in like
15 minutes as the sound got closer
georgia realized she would soon face its
maker
okay here we go
oh cool
fire and flame wrapped her form
hey stop that you'll bring the whole
cave down
but the giant tests just kept on
pounding
yeah just ignore me
it's not like i might die over here very
cool
at least that noise has stopped
the lava gently bubbled
can do
oh wait
can i right here i need to get up there
maybe repair instead
oh jesus
where am i okay so does that work
yes that was
i weird you have to kind of do it a
couple of times to make it actually work
which is confusing
sometimes it looks like oh wait wait
wait wait go away
come back need you
i needed that well i also need a
platform
oh well i'll just die
i think it's like the first hit
initiates it and then the second hit
does it but i'm not too sure because
sometimes
one hit seems to be enough i'm let's
check with this one right so
i don't know i don't know
or maybe this is just a timed thing like
i have to hold it on the object that i
want to rise
yeah i think rice is just timed
have you see it's made the noise to say
that it is
on the thing thing
maybe this is something
don't know
no not again the whole floor is going to
give way
right not listening or ignoring
i don't care voiceover can be a little
bit dicey at times
inside georgia was a white hot
rage most of the time it's good though
for kids especially
oh my gosh oh my gosh
[Music]
oh my gosh this is the giant test i've
just noticed her that's too busy looking
at me trying not to fall off the edge
hey
whoever you are you nearly killed me
she is uh so brave
hello
that's not fair what is wrong with you
[Music]
firehog smash
is that the angry version of you
would you mean her in the game it could
be
he's got her hair almost
i really need to get out of here let's
do it
a timely exit
georgia didn't quite know what she'd
encountered sheesh
a fiery giant she's so angry
the thought stuck with georgia
what's wrong with her
i think i need a breather a place to
rest
oh just like the other like in the dome
the burn of loneliness
oh any magic word
george's thoughts drifted back to the
burning giant house
why would she be so full of rage
she must have felt
um i'm gonna put misunderstood
yeah misunderstood
you're not you when you're hungry have a
snickers
could just be that i could just do that
seriously this seems a lot like a
monster calls
bluejay 1992. i really want to see that
film
if you want to go cry watch that film i
need to see that film
she smashes stuff
because no one understands her
i get that
i think we all went through that
challenge to be more understanding
yes that will that will help if they met
again
that's the light
pushed back the darkness a heaviness
lifted from her heart
dynamite boom baby strangely satisfying
i can definitely get out there come on
what are you doing
oh dynamite
but i don't care
oh no not again
georgia was adrift on the current
without control
lost on the flow of lava
it would take her where it wished
oh
the burning river went faster
and faster
okay we got it we got one more
please say i got the ball i want to have
them all oh yeah
yeah yeah we got this
uh okay georgia
remember empathy
you you
again
she isn't listening
thundering steps shook the earth
[Music]
where is she
it's so close i'm gonna die
and i literally thought i was gonna die
how was this kid's game getting doing
debris was flying everywhere
let's go
go faster go faster gotta go fast
[Music]
freedom
[Music]
yeah just act like a disappointed mother
huh what happened to you no no
don't feel so angry now
just go just let out what's there to be
angry about
i wouldn't squash me if i were you think
of the mass
the smell the giantess smiled
as her anger left it brought a change
oh it's so cute she was doodling that
there was doodles of this thing
behind her journal
lump nice to meet you
i'm georgia sorry i was so
angry lump sorry too
lump scares lump
yes burn the rock that is
how work science
also english i'm what
dragon i don't know about the dragon
but just then georgia noticed a boom
shroom she hadn't seen before
a dream stream that's a that was a cool
name
we did it we're free are you coming
hurry
[Music]
is lump coming
lump you coming
lump likes georgia
we've made a friend a little fiery
friend
hello journal
today sarah at school told me
her grandad had a stroke too
his mouth went lopsided
and he spoke a little funny
now he mostly sits around watching the
telly
i don't think grant would enjoy that
[Music]
she'd feel like she was giving up she'd
want to keep
moving keep doing things
bran always says
give the world your kindness
and it will return
[Music]
oh such good advice
give the world your kindness and it will
return it
threefold the more positive energy and
kindness you
give the world the more you get back
when mr parry's lawn got too high
gran cut it for him
for the community center meals she baked
cakes
[Music]
she even does the unthinkable
what's that oh yeah
[Music]
she changed ben's smelly nappies
someone better step up me
starting with
bringing world peace
cooking for the elderly
cutting mr perry
tidying my room yeah you could probably
do that
[Music]
cute bringing chaos
should play this is such a mighty
struggle needs a
suitable tagline it's tidying time
my cat
oh he did it
oh nice robot
and then i did the washing up from
breakfast
without being asked
amazing
[Music]
dad said
it's a miracle then he bowed at my feet
he's such a complete numpty head
[Music]
and when we got to the hospital later
bran was sitting in a chair and looking
out the window she was smiling
so all the things i've been doing have
been
working
i just have to do more
[Music]
there was kale for tea
kale kind of torture
but i told myself
[Music]
that if i could eat all of it
then gran would be even better tomorrow
[Music]
although you can make kale chips
actually it's not that bad or crisps
sorry
i am on fire today
i ran up the stairs
two at a time just to top things up
pinky was very impressed and slept on my
feet
all night that's so cute
when i was a kid i had cats i tried to
get them to sleep with me
didn't work cats are nocturnal
hello again journal
i couldn't sleep i guess i felt a bit
silly i mean
who cares if i eat my kale
well dad maybe
but does any of this really make a
difference
it's just
[Music]
if there's a sliver of a chance it
actually does
i want to believe in it
[Music]
sarah told me that when her granddad was
sick
she used to pray i don't exactly know
how that works
but best to hedge my bets please
please please
please please
please wait granwell
[Music]
[Music]
sarah's family are pretty religious
not like mom and dad i don't
know that much about religion actually
especially the one about the ark and
rescuing
all the animals
[Music]
oops oh cool
brown was raised catholic
but i never really heard her talk about
god
apart from
that time she dropped the yogurts in
tesco's
we took care of the mess before the
staff noticed
the quran quickly covered my ears
even offered to pay for them
oh wait i wouldn't know what that is
i asked her once she said
if there is a god they're in our actions
how we help and love one another
that's cute
it's a nice way here right to me
so what should i do
i'm going to bring in my story next time
we go to the hospital
i can read it to her i think she'd like
that
maybe if i do a really good job she can
come home in time for ben's birthday
but first i need to get on with the
story
okay i'm gonna call it here
can i
i'm gonna just go into the story and
then i'll call the stream
there because we've been having escape
flaming caves
lump and georgia ventured into
a tenebrous forest thanks theosaurus
writing lump is going to be fun
if she's not so angry anymore she might
need another character flaw
maybe ooh we get to choose one
stop using the theosory
[Music]
heavenly taste but none of the calories
lump doesn't pucker she's pure fire
worse than kale like that's gin socks
what should we say guys stink fruit sour
fruit or sweet food
for a roof over fruit
sour is best sour fruit
sweet fruit sour
okay we've got two for sour so i'm gonna
go for sour
sour fruit
gentle sunlight streamed across their
faces
sun i'm misty
i'm literally gonna tell all my work
colleagues who have kids about this game
that's the dragon we've got to follow it
okay so that's that thank you so much
for watching
it's very very different um but like i
said at the beginning of this stream
it's been a long time since i played
more of an indie game
and i definitely love to support indie
developers
as well as you big
aaa games and uh big devs
so this is really interesting and the
next
big game we've got coming up is resident
evil village so i thought
let's play something really sweet and
cute um before we do that so
let me know if you want me to carry on
playing this uh again next week and
maybe i will cry
because this is way too relatable but i
i honestly think
i think it has some really unique
mechanics in it in terms of narrative
design
um i love the transition from a
journal to like the 3d world space
um it really portrays the idea of like a
kid
in their fantasy world um in their
imagination
it does that really well uh and
this the whole story is so
so good i just think yeah for for a kid
it would be some really good lessons to
be done in like a really fun way as well
very relatable for people our age i'm
sure
[Music]
um but yeah if you want to see this
again give me a thumbs up and i will see
you on thursday
next week uh probably most likely make
sure you follow
me on discord or on twitter and i will
keep you up to date on that